okay right so like you said I will be
talking today about my work in sort of
applying set machine learning techniques
to systems that we would like to control
and feedback and wondering about
robustness guarantees there and
specifically today I'm going to focus on
the case of perception based control
this is joint work with a bunch of my
colleagues at Berkeley aralia
Nikolai Ben Rohan and Vicki without whom
some of the cool videos I'm gonna show
would not exist all right
so machine learning is a promising tool
for processing complex information
that's why I can look you talking about
it that's why everybody is excited about
it some of the successes are in areas
like speech to text or image recognition
object detection and in translation and
what these areas have in common is that
the inputs are sort of this weird mess
of data that may not be clear how to
process otherwise and so learning
provides something really powerful where
you can take datasets and get something
useful and so as a result we're excited
about using this tool to actually act on
the complex information about the world
that we sense
so one example is in games video games
chess alphago was one that people got
really excited about where in this case
the information is given by the board
and the positions on the board and
learning was a really important part of
understanding how to value different
board configurations or different moves
similarly we're also pushing in areas
like robotics to apply image recognition
capabilities to sort of control things
in real time this was an opening an
example of manipulating a cube with a
hand I think it took maybe like the
equivalent of millions of years to Train
but in the end there were some pretty
cool videos right but there's not
necessarily a reliable procedure to do
so we have in the past like I think two
years now had a few fatalities from cars
driving an autonomous
mode including uber and Tesla both have
suffered from problems here as well as
like maybe examples that are more
abstract systems like you two are
criticized for how they might radicalize
individuals walk watching them and what
the assistants have in common is that
there are learned components in feedback
with the real world so what is
challenging here and why is this
unreliable still one is that using
machine learning in this way we're
observing the world partially like we
don't have full state observation we
don't have a Markov decision process in
general we have some kind of partially
observed Markov decision process
there's also distribution shift once you
use a learned component to act on the
world you're changing the world around
you and thus changing the data that will
be put back into that learn component
and finally both of these things sort of
contribute to a lack of robustness when
you don't have state observation
robustness is trickier and when
distributions are changing robustness is
harder to guarantee so that's going to
be the motivation for my talk today and
everything I'm going to say from here
and out will be sort of targeted at this
example of sort of racing from pixels so
the goal here is to drive around an
arbitrary pet track as fast as possible
using just a dashboard mounted camera
and so this is illustrative because in
this situation we're going to be pushing
against performance limits as we get
faster and faster and that will let us
understand why driving from a camera are
using learned components for the camera
might fail add the caveat that I'll say
is this is not totally realistic if you
want to make a car that drives around
racetracks you should probably have a
lot more sensors there's a lot more
tuning you can do there's a lot of
careful work that has been done in
robotics so this is not purely realistic
and the way that I'll talk about it
though is well we'll use models for
control physics so let's say that we do
know something about the world we do
understand how the world changes so we
understand the dynamics but we will use
learning for perception so in this case
although there is a lot of good work in
visual odometry let's suppose that we
would like something more general
approach or we don't have to
characterize cameras or
very formally we just want to learn that
from data and so this approach can be
successful so this is a teaser I'll show
a video like this again at the end of
the talk and explain it in more detail
but this is an example of a one-tenth
sized RC car driving around sort of this
track defined by this rope at pretty
high speed so this is what the dashboard
camera view looks like and there are a
few more sensors we're using for control
here but the main sort of sensor for
position comes from doing a sort of
localization method on these images and
these are features that the cameras
picking out so it can be successful it
can be really useful but it can also
fail so sometimes when you drive the car
we might drive around this very small
office space if we don't get to rent the
wazniak lounge in time and then
sometimes the car will crash sometimes
it will hit objects and not actually act
like we would like it to and so the
question is why does it do this and I'll
answer that today by framing the problem
in a more simplified setting than
reality but something that can hopefully
illustrate what's going on so I'm going
to start with setting up this problem
the simplified problem and show how it
relates to output feedback optimal
control so many tasks that we would like
a system to do can be modeled as an
optimal control task so for example if
we have a car that we would like to move
over to that point over there where the
star is and we know how the car moves in
reaction to some input so this is F
equals MA and then we can write the
derivative of velocity acceleration and
the derivative of position is velocity
so our model from physics then I can
write out some optimization problem that
describes my desire for the car to move
sort of quickly but without too much
input force to the star over there so
this is sort of stylized but we have
some minimizing minimization of a cost
function subject to some known dynamics
here and sometimes this problem is not
easy sometimes we're in situations where
like maybe these things aren't as clear
but a lot of the time we know the models
we have a good proxy for the cost and so
this is easy when states are directly
observed what happens
in sort of the driving example that I
just showed or a lot of other things is
that we don't observe the states
directly but we instead have some
observation function so this cost and
these dynamics are the same as before
I'm just writing a little bit more
generally but what's different is that Z
is some high dimensional observation
from the world and that we need to
design a controller that acts on Z not
on X so on observation not on State and
so there obviously this is a problem
that exists in the world engineers have
done a lot of cool things one
traditional approach relies on physical
modeling to sort of reduce a sensing
complexity by doing state estimation and
here you would do some kind of maybe
extended a common filter which would
take into account the dynamics and this
sort of generating procedure so G is
like this appearance map which Maps a
state to an image so it's generally
pretty complex pretty hard to specify I
don't work in graphics but I know that
that's an entire field of research so
this EKF is sort of tries to reduce that
complexity and estimate an underlying
state and then we can just do control on
underlying state as if we had state
observation and this is successful lots
of systems work this way but the
modeling part might be kind of annoying
or maybe we want to use sensors that you
don't have good characterizations for
you and we wanted to do some automatic
calibration or something at the very
other end of the spectrum is this
end-to-end approach where instead of
having to worry about how we would
estimate a state carefully we can just
use data to say well in the end of the
day the procedure that I showed here is
ultimately deciding the control action
based on the series of images that I
observed for example so I can do that
directly right and maybe if I have
enough data that's something that would
be successful I said already what I'm
going to talk about here which is going
to be something in the middle some sort
of hybrid approach where we keep our
optimal control problem and just change
this observation from Z which is some
complex high dimensional thing to Y
which is going to be much simpler maybe
a linear function of the state so to
make this more concrete let's say this
is the car driving F
is the dynamics of the car ex is like
the velocity and the position and
perhaps why I'll define as just the
position because I may not be able to
you know get the velocity of the car
from a single image but I should
reliably be able to predict position of
the car let's say and then I can design
a controller based on all of these
positions the position history over time
and so we have a block diagram it looks
sort of like this right we have the car
in the environment generates a state the
camera generates an image from that by
passing it through a perception
component we can then do sort of output
feedback control and specifically what
I'll talk about here is a linear setting
where we have linear dynamics so F is an
our linear function we have a compact
observation model given by G like I said
but we're going to reduce the complexity
by saying that instead we actually
observe some linear subset of the state
so for example position plus some error
where these errors are now defined by
you know sort of the composition of
appearance perception minus off what I'm
trying to predict right so this is this
is sort of true by definition if you
plug these things back together but this
is the way we're going to model it and
the reason that we're in a model its way
is because looks sort of familiar where
we have this sort of you know idealized
system and perception here which looks
simple it looks like a linear control
problem and then we have some perception
error block that we're gonna have to
deal with so this is a familiar setting
like I was getting at of linear output
feedback control and this is well study
I don't know how many of you have taken
you know control classes but I'm sure
you've seen these types of equations
before and so depending on how we model
the cost how we model the process noise
W and how we model the measurement noise
II there's sort of well studied
solutions that we could do
however sort of me the most famous
example of this would be the linear
quadratic Gaussian controller and so
here we would model the process noise
and the measurement noise discussion but
remember our measurement noise is coming
from this error in perceptions
there's no real reason to believe with
Goshen so we're gonna have to do a
little bit more thinking about this just
an aside but while I go forward I'm
really motivating this talk now with low
level control as the example so in this
situation what I'm saying is that my car
sort of designs a low level controller
to follow for example waypoints so that
you know this star might be a waypoint
and I say how are you gonna control the
motors to get to that Waypoint that's a
very low level task and often especially
in robotics and we think about how we
might use a sensor like a camera that's
not really the task for thinking
directly about we might be thinking
something like we already have a
low-level Waypoint following controller
we're not really using the camera for
that but we follow waypoints based on
some path planner and you know if we
want to use the camera for that we're
really closing the loop in a different
way so you know instead of waypoints as
like this specific position maybe we
have a high level goal like drive and
park in the corner and this kind of goal
would be fed into the system and the
camera would be used along with a
perception and path planner to decide
how to set up waypoints that would maybe
bring me to park in the corner I bring
this up just to say that although I will
be motivating the rest of the talk with
its weight point tracking example I want
you guys to keep in mind that what I'm
saying applies for any system that has
this perception to loop type of feedback
right so anytime I'm using some learned
component to make decisions about my
system so with that said I hinted at
this before but if I don't know the
model of my errors it's not a hummert's
not clear how to solve a linear optimal
control problem so the first thing we're
going to talk about is now perception
errors so how do we learn this
perception component what do we do with
images can we talk about generalization
in this setting so for this talk because
I'm worried about the composition of
these two pieces I'm not focusing on the
particulars of the perception map and
how you learn it what I would like to do
is characterize a sufficient condition
for stability and that's what I'm going
to get to in this section I think
there's a lot of interest
ways that you can get at these
properties that are more specific to
images more specific to neural networks
or to visual odometry that I'll talk a
little bit about at the end and that I'd
love to talk about more afterwards but
for this setting let's just say we learn
some Mac P from pairs of states and
images and for simplicity let's just
assume that we actually have zero
training data a training error so that
we sort of interpolate the training data
if I've driven the car along this path
and collected training data at these
points then if I try to drive it along
the second path I would maybe expect
that it should still you know be able to
perceive its location pretty well but if
I start driving all the way in this
other direction I'm probably not so much
why would I believe that my perception
map should continue working and so that
motivates us to think about this safe
set around training data as long as we
stay near where the perception performs
well we can hope that it will perform
well which is kind of circular but let's
think about what is learning theory have
to say about this you know machine
learning talks a lot about you know
training site testing set errors
generalization you know it's not going
to help us here so a quick intro or
quick yeah very quick whirlwind tour of
what that has to say
so empirical risk minimization this is
not the only way to learn things but it
is probably the most common is that I
would find my perception map P by
minimizing some loss function over all
my data points so all my data points zi
x i these are states and observations
like images for example i minimize this
loss function over what i've observed
this is called empirical risk
minimization so you know the some of the
risk is some of the losses is my risk
it's empirical because I'm doing it over
an empirical distribution but what I
care about is something like the
population risk so not just what happens
on the data I observe but what happens
from new data planes drawn from some
distribution so the classic approach
says that if I have a new data point
drawn from the same distribution as my
training points I can define the
empirical risk as that expected loss
and then my question is you know if my
loss was sort of generally small and my
training data what will it look like on
my testing data well if I draw from the
same distribution again I can sort of
write that my population risk is my
empirical risk plus my population risk -
my empirical risk right sort of very
complicated expression here and then I
can since I said my training data was
zero in this case for simplicity I'm
really just banning things by this
difference so the difference between you
know the two things like I the one thing
I have which is empirical risk and the
one thing that I care about which is
population risk in the nice case of you
know standard machine learning these are
an empirical distribution with a real
distribution and because you know lots
of statistics over the years has done
really a beautiful analysis for us we
can say that actually empirical
distributions approximate distributions
as n gets large and we can maybe bound
this value as one of us buried under
something so this is like what a
learning rate would look like this would
make us happy and it would say get more
data we sort of get better but you know
we're not when we control a system we're
not drawing new states randomly and
asking how well our perception is going
to perform so what happens if there's
distribution shift like just because I
you know drove the car around a circle
here and had low loss what if I veer off
into the center or something then I'm
going to seal out data points that don't
necessarily look so good right so there
are sort of ways to approach this from a
statistical perspective that look at
sort of maybe the empirical risk over a
new distribution d-prime where it will
be a similar story to before but now
we're concerned about the distance
between the two distribution -
distributions and you can define this as
a statistical difference but actually
what I'm going to do moving forward is
get away from statistics it's not really
helpful in this setting because they
don't have random sampling I don't have
IAT data what I have is something in
feedback but I am going to hold on to
this idea of distribution shift so
instead of a statistical generalization
I'm going to think about maybe
deterministic or
ferial generalization you know like I
said the closed loop states the
distribution of states that I will see
during operating mice while operating my
system depend on that perception map I
train in the first place but I'm
controlling the system so I actually
have some say in what distribution of
states I might observe and so the idea
is to actually leverage the control
authority to ensure closeness right like
make the car drive around this area
where I think my errors are small or my
loss is good and that's that is what I'm
gonna do the question is is this
possible right so the one way to ensure
this at least from the perspective of
your perception map and the areas that
it has is given by an idea of a slope
bound a slope boundedness so if the
composition of my perception of my
appearance map so this is something that
you know appearance is based on where
you are in a room so this might be like
where all the chairs are what colors
they are you know very complicated
my perception map I could look at visual
features and sort of map them against a
database of features and guess my
position as I move the appearance map
might be somewhat smooth right like if I
look this way and this way there's not
that much of a difference in what I see
but if something really close to me then
maybe that's not so smooth at the same
time the perception map right is taking
in images and predicting position and so
it's sort of this high dimensional input
space usually we don't think of those
functions as necessarily being smooth
right and that's why things like
adversarial images exist or people have
like you know really cute examples of
like making a stop sign classifier think
that it's something totally different
and so that's not what I'm asking to
guarantee in the situation I'm not
asking for the perception map itself
should be smooth just for this
composition with the real world to be
smooth so as long as you input real
images that were generated that should
very sort of smoothly slope boundedness
is just a little bit more general than
smoothness but you can think of this as
like a Lipschitz smoothness condition so
as long as my areas satisfy this which
is sort of a reasonable thing you might
hope perception maps are satisfied then
I
founded heirs around my training data
right so as I move away from a training
data point my errors don't grow by too
much and s is the parameter that's going
to control that and then I can use this
to say here's a set where the errors are
small this is very different from
traditional generalization but it might
feel a very natural to a control
engineer for example defining a region
that we believe is safe and that we
would like to operate in
and speaking of control let's move sort
of into that part of this argument how
do we you know have we have in a region
that we think is say if we have a map we
think we can perceive the world within
that's that set how do we actually make
sure we stay in that set how do we act
within that set so that's where robust
control is going to come into play so
like I said our goal is to ensure that
the system stays within the safe set
despite the measurement error so despite
these perception errors II that I know
I'm gonna have Wow potentially
optimizing some performance right our
goal is to drive a car on the racetrack
really fast so we would like to sort of
do all these things at the same time
there's a lot of approaches to this so
one really natural one and the demo
actually is based off of this kind of
approach is a model predictive control
approach so this is a receding horizon
controller that sort of optimizes
performance for some finite time horizon
while satisfying certain constraints and
then sort of reap lands at every time
stuff this is super useful in practice
but unfortunately it's a lot more
difficult to get a handle on you know
when am I going to guarantee that this
controller is feasible and these types
of arguments tend to be a little bit
more loose so I'm gonna make the
argument using a different way to talk
about closed-loop systems and robust
control which is called system level
synthesis and this is a approach to
controller design that looks at
specifically the map from the process
noise in the measurement area so these
two area signals to the states and the
inputs of the system so I sort of cover
up everything that's happening inside so
instead of worrying about just the
controller K I sort of just worried
about the whole response and so now I'm
going to do a brief introduction to this
way of
about systems I think it's really useful
and hopefully you'll see that by the end
why I think it's useful but yeah so
let's start with state feedback so
remember we're in the setting of output
feedback because we don't actually see
you know the world perfectly because we
have this weird sensing modality but for
the purposes of introduction let's go
back to state feedback that's always a
nice case though is the easy case
so in close loop the state and the input
of a system are actually just a linear
function of disturbances to see why
that's true remember that the state of a
system is written and can be written in
terms of the inputs and the disturbances
write this by sort of unrolling that
recursion but then because we have a
linear controller well okay as long as
you have a linear controller this is
true because we have a linear controller
we can also write the inputs as a
function of the states and if we put
these two equations together and you
know do some rearranging we can actually
just write the state in the input as
directly functions of that disturbance
so very transparent map between what
goes into the system and what comes out
and in what follows I'm going to like
sort of simplify notation a little bit
by talking about sort of signals and
operators so instead of thinking about
each X T I'm going to think about sort
of the sequence of all the X's
it could be finite it could be infinite
notationally it's not going to matter
I'm also gonna think about the sequence
of all the use and the sequence of all
the W's the disturbances so this thing
here this V X V u that's sort of an
operator that operates on these infinite
horizon signals and returns other sort
of potentially infinite horizon signals
you can it's just a convolutional
operator it's sort of what you would get
from stacking this expression into like
this huge toklas matrix but notationally
that's all it means is something that
operates on a noise signal and gives me
my states in my inputs and so we can use
this identity that I just sort of wrote
down this linear relationship to derive
a new optimal control problem so
remember my original optimal control
problem I have some cost so I'm going to
write things in our in terms of linear
quadratic control because that
where everything is easy to write if I
minimize some quadratic cost subject to
the dynamics and subject to the control
being a linear function of the state
this is sort of the optimal control
problem and if I reformulate that in
terms of signals it doesn't look too
different it's actually more beautiful
in my opinion because I don't have to
write any subscripts which is annoying
to type but I have the same thing right
so I sort of have this quadratic cost I
have these linear dynamic constraints
and linear controller constraints and
you know I might actually also have
state and input constraints this is
really realistic for something that you
do in practice where you also don't want
to crash the car into a wall but you
would actually just stay on the track
but if I know that my state and my input
are just linear functions of the
disturbance I could rewrite this whole
thing just in terms of these system
responses so that linear function and
the disturbance and then I can actually
take the expectation over the
disturbance if I'm assuming it's noisy
or whatever and I get this also a very
beautiful expression that has no
subscripts so in this case I still have
a quadratic cost right I'm still sort of
doing this norm minimization I still
have some sort of like affine
constraints a and B that are determining
my dynamics and I'm still gonna have
some sort of constraints on the system
response that correspond to these so
there's sort of a nice translation
between thinking about things in terms
of states and inputs and a controller
and feedback and then thinking about the
whole closed loop response as a single
thing and that's what system level
synthesis is it's just a formalization
of this kind of cute observation and it
formally says that there is a
correspondence so if I design a system
using that sort of optimal control
problem I just showed you as long as it
lies in that affine space defined by a
and B there is a controller realization
don't worry too much about the form I
can use the system response to design a
controller that then achieve that exact
response in closed loop which is cool
right because usually when I think about
what I would like a system to do it's
about how I would like it sort of to
respond how I would like it to react to
his error signals and now I can design
that
and as long as I constrain it in the
right way everything will be good so
that's really nice
why would I do that though I could just
do normal optimal control well the real
reason that I'm interested in this
personally I think this since system
level synthesis also has applications to
things like distributed control but
personally my sort of reason for getting
into this weird new optimal control
robust control framework is because of
unknown dynamics so if I'm designing you
know a controller but I don't really
know how the dynamics progress
I would instead have some a hat and B
hat and so I can you know have some
estimated X hat and u hat and I think
that's what's going to happen when I put
things in closed loop but um I don't
really know because I'm planning in
something totally different than what's
going to happen and it's not totally
clear how to translate between those two
things but the really nice thing is that
in system response space so I sort of
lifted from signals into you know
transfer functions if a system lies in
the estimated dynamic space so a hat and
B hat space I can actually sort of
rearrange this equation and take a
matrix inverse and find out that this
weird-lookin system response lies in the
a/b space and that's cool because this
new weird-looking response then tells me
how my system will act in the presence
of these additional errors in a and B
and then there is like sort of a
condition for this to be true which is
that the norm of so basically this
inverse has to exist and the way to
guarantee that it would exist for any
Delta a and Delta B is to constrain the
estimated system responses norm to be
less than and sorry this epsilon is the
size of these areas Delta a and Delta B
okay so I have some equations on the
board I said suddenly I magically know
how systems are going to act under these
uncertainties which seems unrealistic
because if I knew the uncertainty I
would have designed into them in the
first place and that's totally true this
is sort of an expression for how the
true system will react to disturbances
even though I designed an estimated
system and I can write it down of course
this Delta in this case
is just this Delta a delta B term I
don't know what that is right I don't
know what my air is in a and B R I don't
know what my my estimation errors are
because if I did then this wouldn't be a
problem in the first place
but this does give us something to work
with right we can try to bound this
quantity and think about how that
uncertainty will affect how things
propagate and that's exactly what we do
so just to sort of put this up again
formally right if we design in the
estimated space and we use that
estimated controller we get this sort of
nice-looking system response and this
has been really useful as a paradigm for
analyzing learning and control by sort
of transparently understanding how these
not only like disturbances but also the
error is an estimation match to the
closed-loop behavior as a caveat we're
still in the state feedback setting
eventually we're going to get back to
perception and we're going to get back
to output feedback but this has been
most useful so far in the case of
learning with state feedback and so we
use system level synthesis we use this
robust control framework to understand
how sub-optimal a controller is with
respect to those errors so the dynamics
estimation errors and then we use
statistics to bound the uncertainty of
those errors as we get more data and by
putting these two things together we can
sort of get these full sample complexity
bounds of how do my how does my
controller act as I get more and more
data and I've done this work sort of in
the setting of a robust adaptive control
so this is sort of where you're in
real-time trying to both estimate and
act optimally and there's some trade-off
between you sort of exploring the system
by injecting noise and exploiting the
system by trying to design an optimal
controller then I've also done this in
the setting of learning while satisfying
constraints right so I don't know the
system I need to excite it to learn
something about it but I also don't want
to violate some safety constraints I
don't want to crash into a wall or
whatever we can also analyze what
learning looks like in that case using
this framework but that's not actually
I'm talking about today although I hope
it motivated you to sort of stay with me
through all that math today we're
thinking about perception based controls
so right we have a car we have some
what we're trying to say is how can we
make this car stay in the safe set and
we have the system we're asking the
question of staying in the safe set is
really asking can I ensure that my exes
stays safe despite these measurement
errors that I know that I have so now we
will get back to that output feedback
assistant level synthesis looks very
similar to state feedback we just have a
few more terms now so instead of just
having two terms you have four because
we have two signals and then still
states and inputs and we have this sort
of same relationship between designing
in an affine space and then achieving a
response and I'm actually not going to
go into the robust version of this for
now because all I really want is this
transparent map to my perception errors
which I've got so all right we're all
good we sort of at least symbolically
think we understand how our errors are
going to propagate through to our states
and that gives us hope for saying that
those states will stay safe and in fact
they do so sort of just by writing the
expression that I had on the previous
slide and then thinking about our
distance from training errors if we do
if we close the loop with the controller
from a system response then we can
remain close to training data so X minus
X D is going to be the distance of our
closed loop States from any state in the
trainings in the training data set it's
bounded by sort of how much we plan to
deviate from the training set plus this
extra term that depends on a particular
part of that system response so this is
the system response that map's
measurement error to state I mean
writing it down it seems like true
almost by definition right the size of
the error times the map from area to
state is my additional air over my
planned deviation for my training data
so this expression says as long as this
is true you will stay in your training
data another way to look at this that
might be more appealing if you don't
want to do linear control is that this
is a condition that sort of lets me
reason about set invariants of that set
around my training data yes
could you also rewrite this as a way of
guiding your exploration to increase
your support yeah yes exactly so the one
caveat for that in this setting is that
because we have this observation
framework where we're just seeing images
during observation or during operation
and we don't have additional state
labels the relearning things are like
guiding exploration the setting is a
little bit subtle to talk about right so
yes sorry let me say it again so in
supervised learning we have labels and
features our features here are the
images or like you know some feature
eyes' version of them the labels are the
states and so I probably glossed over
this a little bit too much before but I
was assuming that we during training we
have those labels which when you then
talk about an online setting of
exploration exploitation suddenly that
assumption seems a lot worse because if
you really had said observation for
exploration then maybe you should just
use that for control but it still does
actually say something about how you
should design your training data
essentially and if you could come up
with an unsupervised method for updating
your perception map where you only have
access to images over time which is
actually one of the directions of future
work that I'll mention then this would
exactly sort of show you how you could
sort of guide exploration at the edges
of your safe set to add more points to
the to the safe side
exactly so yes that this kind of
reasoning about what trajectories are
going to happen could be used to then
design trajectories that will give you
more data okay and then just one example
in case anybody really loves LQG or
something and wants to understand what
this slide means in terms of that system
so just to recall like linear quadratic
Gaussian problem the optimal solution to
that is a combination of static feedback
on an estimated state with state
estimation with like a static observer
right so my estimated state I run it
through the dynamics and I
include an update term based on the real
wide that I observed from the system and
then I just used the estimated state to
control the system in this case we can
actually like write out what is this
what is this map that I'm like saying
exists that we need to control the
normal this map from measurement error
to state sort of has this form you can
see it depends on sort of a plus B case
so that's sort of like the stability of
the state feedback controller a minus LC
is a stability of the observer and this
like BK term you know take a power of
matrices looks kind of messy they take
away that I want to point out is that
having a large K and L here there's sort
of a trade-off right so K is how much
you listen how much you control how
large your controller response is to the
estimated state and L is how large your
estimated responses to the observed
output in this case if either of them
are too small you might not be
stabilizing your system enough and so
these terms the diagonal could be big
right if a is like close to unstable on
the other hand this term and this term
both have a K and an L in them so if K
and L are too large then you're also
very sensitive so there is some sweep
sweet spot in terms of being responsive
enough to the system that that you can
maintain like stability but not being
too responsive so you know this
expression looks kind of ugly
and that's like why I like to work in
the system responses but just to give a
little bit more intuition for maybe what
I'm saying when I talk about this map
all right so all right I dragged
everybody through generalization and
machine learning I dragged everybody
through robust control what was the
point so the point is that I can say
this under sort of the previous
functions of the last two lemmas that
generalization implies closeness and
closeness implies generalization lemmas
as long as I have this sort of
sensitivity sensitivity bounds so the
sensitivity of the system to measurement
errors is bounded by the slope constant
of my perception errors then we have
that the closed-loop objectory is within
the state safe set and the perception
error
are bounded in a way that depends on a
bunch of different things the
measurement sensitivity sorry
measurement sensitivity the planned
deviation from the training data and the
slope band yes can you be like adversary
about measurements and test whether or
not like yeah so I guess I'll say that
all of these these conditions are true
even under adversarial there's but they
require sort of the assumption of a
slope bound that holds no matter what so
any like regardless of how you tried to
be as adversarial as possible with
measurement errors as long as they
satisfy sort of a smoothness around
training data then you're safe on the
flip side the fact that this is
potentially true even under adversarial
areas means that it is probably pretty
conservative and that's like a thing in
robust control that is constantly true
and there's always a trade-off and
there's definitely room to sort of bring
a slightly more statistical perspective
into like loosen that up a little bit
but and actually yeah in talking about
sort of adversarial and worst case that
you regionally do you actually have an
example I think in like a slide or two
but before I get there let me just
looking at the the guarantees of this
theorem what they're really saying is
that as long as I have this sort of
limited measurement sensitivity then I
have set invariance around my training
data that's sort of the high level
takeaway and that how that will take
away I think it's something that can be
applied more generally to even nonlinear
systems all right so okay cool I can
specialize this result sort of a
reference tracking task to give a little
bit more intuition for what these things
mean I'm gonna go a little bit faster
this because I want to have plenty of
time to show videos essentially if my
reference tracking task is sort of the
difficulty of it is controlled by the
distance between two waypoints that I'm
trying to track as well as the distance
from waypoints to training data then the
perception areas are bounded as long as
this whole thing is less than one so
what is this saying well the s and this
distance from my reference distance for
my training data those are about the
quality of my person
should map and the sort of coverage of
my training data so the more training
data I get the smaller this distance
would be and the better my perception
map the smoother sort of like more
adapted to the setting the smaller this
s would be on the other hand the Delta
ref and the DRF are both measures of how
difficult the task is so we sort of see
this in this expression something that
is illustrative about how training data
and learning can limit your ability to
sort of achieve difficult tasks because
this whole thing has to be bounded by
one there's also two terms here that
depend on your design system response so
you can try to make these firm small but
eventually they can't both be 0 because
these are sort of terms that lie in this
affine space and so you can't infinitely
make them small so the system itself is
going to have some limits there I'm not
gonna talk about this only to say that
with the adversarial question before I
sort of said you know any any errors the
system will be safe as long as it
satisfies these conditions but that
obviously could be very conservative
this example is just to say that there
are some systems and some type of errors
where it's actually not a conservative
condition it's sort of an if and only if
condition where if I have this sort of
particular position position miss
calibration in the perception map then
if I don't constrain the controller in
this way under synthesis I will be
unstable and otherwise I won't be
unstable yeah now I get to go to the
demos which is what I am rushing towards
so first I'm gonna talk about a
simulated setting here we're using Carla
which is like an open source simulator
where you could sort of generate street
views and pretend to drive a car we're
not actually using any fancy car
dynamics for this setting we're using
this like hovercraft dynamics we call it
which is a 2d double integrator so we
assume we have perfect control over X
and y position and we're going to look
at two different types of perception
Maps I hinted at this before but one is
is visual odometry where my perception
map simply feature eise's an image and
then looks up in a database images that
sort of match that image and then I do a
special like geometric transformation
between the features in both images to
try to figure out how far I am from the
other image so it's kind of like nearest
neighbors plus some geometry to give you
something very good that works really
well in robotics and the training method
here is sort of a simultaneous location
localization and mapping algorithm we
use orbs lamb and there's only 200
points in the training set so I'm kind
of doing nearest neighbors on 200 points
with special geometry on the other hand
we did like a very simple convolutional
neural network which was just
single-layer had rel use and a max pool
and we trained this one with 30,000
points it took a lot more but to be fair
also had no special geometric structure
or anything else and our simulation
results the goal here was to find
something that might fail without
special tuning and that sort of adding
this robustness condition to would sort
of fix that right because we're trying
to look for failures to understand when
they occur in the visual odometry
setting if you look down here this is
how far we are from our reference
trajectory what we are mostly doing
really well and the reason we're doing
so well you can kind of see is that our
perception errors as a function of
distance from the training data they're
like pretty small they're very nicely
sloped and it's sort of if I really
don't move too far away from training it
or they stay quite small on the other
hand the neural network did not sort of
like have these as a nice properties to
be clear like our goal was we're not
experts our goal was not to make this
work super well I don't okay I do kind
of want to come away from the saying
that maybe like slam visual odometry are
good and neural networks are bad but
that's we didn't do enough work to
really say that we just got something
that kind of worked it really did not
work very well if we just had these
nominal controllers that didn't account
for potential sensitivities but it did
work if we sort of constrained the
controller to act in a very smooth way
with respect to these fairly large
errors
any questions yeah what we're like
failures in York it's like is that like
is that just like the distance there's a
the distance from the reference
trajectory is sort of what we're
measuring as quality in this case I can
show you the example actually what a
failure looks like for for this is the
visual odometry so really in this case
failure occurs because we fail to match
so we sort of like fail to find the
right features we fail to match me in
the database and then right like in this
method we just like drive forever into
the distance and because it's simulator
we drive through buildings and stuff
something similar happens with the
neural network except that it's not
quite as possible because we just sort
of have this black box method that's
telling us position based on image so
yeah I have a little bit of time left so
actually I'm okay on time I have time
left so then I will I will now show that
this also works sort of in practice at
least to do iterative racing on
arbitrary tracks in this case the first
lap is a human demonstration of the
track shape the second two laps are PID
control just reference following around
that first lap to gather more data and
also during the first lap we sort of do
mapping and then during the second laps
and all the preceding lasts we just do
localization the rest of the laps and I
think in this case there's like maybe 30
of them we use this iterative learning
and PC strategy which was developed by
some people at Berkeley uber salia and
francesco Pirelli and this allows the
car to sort of drive faster
after each lap by using data from
previous labs what's special about this
method for MPC is that the terminal cost
so MPC I mentioned before it's a
receding horizon strategy we have a
finite control problem finite time
control problem that is replanned at
every time step so the because it's
finite the terminal cost sort of matters
a lot if I'm planning over sort of short
horizon and you know there's a wall like
10 stops in front of me but I'm only
planning 2 steps if I don't sort of plan
correctly I might end up running in
the wall so this terminal cost matters a
lot as does the terminal constraint set
and by updating that with data from
previous laps you can sort of get really
nice behavior where a car for example
learns to cut corners and die faster so
this is a little illustration of the car
the red is the planning horizon and the
green is sort of this safe set that
we're planning to reach the terminal set
that we're reaching and I point that out
because I'm gonna show you the video now
which just illustrates what I just told
you was gonna happen so in this case
human the human is driving the car with
the joystick around this track pretty
slowly because we're not very good at
driving the rope is actually only there
for us to see the track it's not really
one of the visual features that's used
and you can see here from what the
camera is observing the rope is not a
huge part of that
we're mostly seeing like the chairs the
wall specifically what we're using for
localization here is these are these
features these key points that are
mapped against and matched against some
database from our first lab and that is
what is used throughout for the
remaining labs now in this experiment
we're actually no longer updating our
sort of perception training data we're
not updating that initial database in
practice we find that driving faster and
upping the database at the same time
sort of lead to failures in a weird way
that we're thinking about understanding
you could imagine an iterative thing
where you learn you add to your training
data more sort of midway through but
even without that we still do learn to
drive much faster after about 20 laps so
you can see here even our planned
trajectories there's much more space
between these points we're planning to
drive much faster and at this point the
dashboard camera it does look pretty
like that you know it's not crazy we've
actually have a little bit of a faster
demo now with better tuning on the
camera but we can mostly detect these
key points although we do have lapses in
them as you move fast because of the
fast movement of the camera and that's
really what I want to talk about and
just point out as I
wrapup is that this example just
illustrates how we end up being limited
by the perception strategy that we have
so as performance improves the control
task becomes more difficult so this NPC
strategy is not a waypoint tracking
problem but it is sort of analogous to a
waypoint tracking problem where we
adaptively choose our waypoints in the
beginning we saw you know the little
drawing looks something like this where
we have a car with a fairly short
planning horizon this safe set that
we're trying to reach is fairly close to
the car
sort of like an easy task but as the car
drove a lot faster and get the
performance that we're excited about the
planning horizon is much longer and
we're now planning to reach a safe set
that is much further away and so if we
make this analogy to waypoint tracking
the Waypoint that we're trying to reach
sort of becomes much further becomes
much further away from the car so that's
sort of our Delta ref example so how far
away is the Waypoint that we're trying
to reach and it also moves away from the
training data like I said the training
data is just from the centerline of the
track and so as we cut corners we're
also moving away potentially from that
and so for this reason we see that we're
sort of pushing more against the limits
of what we would expect the system to be
able to do safely and so that's sort of
suggestive I have not yet fully closed
the gap between this demo and some of
the theoretical work around why it would
or wouldn't work and that's ongoing
stuff now but just to say the key
takeaways I'd say are the system can
safely operate near its training data
and that by leveraging control Authority
you can sort of sidestep issues of
distribution shift and really what this
means in other words is that we can
construct an invariant set around
training data as long as the designed
closed loop system satisfies a stability
property there's a lot of Direction's I
think that you can take as work forward
with one is an extension to receding
horizon control or nonlinear dynamics I
have throughout tried to pepper in the
phrases that might apply in those
settings but the work to actually
formally do that has not been done yet
the second one that I hinted out a
little bit earlier is unsupervised
learning right
if we're operating the car in real time
we don't have access to new labels of
what state I'm at how do I actually get
better so the slam method the
localization method that I showed
actually is semi unsupervised because we
don't have ground true if you don't have
a bike on setting there I'm so sort of
formalizing that and thinking about how
you can use that adaptively would be
really interesting and then lastly is
this tighter coupling between perception
and dynamics for like learning and for
operation to sort of get even better
better performance and so with that I'll
thank you and take any questions these
are some of the references throughout
the talk I was wondering if you have
like camera image itself so how is it
that is in the setting where you have
slam it depends on how this yeah that's
a great point all of that is sort of
pushed into this idea of a slope bound
essentially in other words like a slope
bound is sort of the sufficient thing
you need to characterize the closed loop
behavior but you're totally right so one
of the future directions actually is
that you know if you use slam to map or
region you have some database
essentially of frames with key points
and these are three dimensional points
and so you can look back at those points
that you've mapped and say like if I'm
in any particular spot in the room will
I see do I expect to see enough points
to then match in the database and that
would be one sort of like not like one
way to characterize that slope and in to
characterize a safe set that would rake
heavily rely on the structure of slam if
that makes sense that would encode
things like if the light on one side of
the room is really bright and this is
actually an issue you run into if we
don't get the good conference room at
night is that the camera just
as the auto-exposure can't keep up and
so there are parts of the space where we
don't have good features we don't have
good images and if you sort of look at
the map constructed by slam you see that
so it's all in the slope and I think
there's work to be done to sort of tease
that out a little bit more over time you
if you train your system you play that
night you have to forget this so in this
case I'm really talking about like
interpolation and like standing around
training data and non bearing
environments so like what you said is
true like nothing I mean nothing that I
formerly wrote applies in that case slam
because it sort of uses features in
geometry in a particular way that is
more invariant to lighting changes as
long as the camera exposure it matches
maybe would work and I think that's
definitely interesting
so one prospect that apparently is true
although I don't personally know of it
is that the so the people who sort of
invented it or like SLS as a way of
looking at systems are all at Caltech
and I visited a few weeks ago and they
told me that it all parses for nonlinear
systems as well so like the expressions
that I wrote about like sort of
operators would apply for non linear
operators so it's like they you know
easy answer the hard answer is that like
even though the expression might apply
the computation would not apply anymore
so it's not that I wasn't clear how this
what this says for synthesizing
nonlinear controllers for nonlinear
systems but I think you could use some
like set invariance ideas and I'm like
really not a nonlinear control expert at
all but I think there are some set
invariance idea like control barrier
functions like I think Aaron was here
last week and probably talked about them
he tried to convince me that that would
help in this setting and maybe a will so
I think that's like one of the
approaches anything around set
invariance basically about this question
in your case you have everything is
nonlinear
yourself algorithm right so you apply
the algorithm to match your framework on
the car oh yeah
so I mean percept yeah the slam itself
is on the new your perception is
nonlinear that's fine for the framework
it's the dynamics being nonlinear that
doesn't totally match we do like MPC
like receding horizon control and so we
linearize the dynamics for each of those
receiving horizons actually and so we
actually haven't done this yet but the
plan is to actually implement that sort
of norm sensitivity constraint in a
receding horizon version of the SLS
framework essentially and we're hoping
that that I know it's a trade-off
between sort of like over a robot overly
robust and like actually helping so
that's something that we're working on
now yeah other system response yeah so I
the yes
the like fee x ii that like measurement
noise two-state map i think you can
write an equivalent EULA expression like
if you sort of like go there's a
relationship between system responses
and controllers and there's a
relationship between controllers and
EULA and so I think there's definitely
connections that you could write an
expression in terms of a EULA parameter
that would apply and it actually it's
possible to be fairly simple in this
case although I'm not sure if it would
like look nice or not
cool that takes us to 12 so let's finger
speaker
[Applause]